let's start with a guy who was once the
first overall pick of the
houston texans jadavian clowney traded
last year
on labor day weekend to the seahawks at
the time when he was subject to the
franchise tag
hadn't shown up for anything hadn't
signed the tender
next thing you know the texans kick in
seven million to get a deal done
he goes to seattle macy's in the
background by the way he goes to seattle
he spends a year there and then he
spends six months
almost on the open market finally
agreeing to terms with the tennessee
titans now
it was an interesting saturday night
because even though there was a report
that the deal was done with tennessee
the deal wasn't done with tennessee
and there were efforts made by teams
like the saints and the seahawks to get
back into it and to get clowney to
choose them
over tennessee at the end of the day
though he decided to reunite with mike
grebel who was the defensive coordinator
in houston before becoming the head
coach of the tennessee titans and that
relationship
presumably went a long way to get
clowney to take an offer
reportedly worth up to 15 million
dollars which means
the base value is less than that we
don't know how much less
i had heard last night the talk was in
the range of 12 million dollars
what does he have to do to earn the
difference and the reality is
he went for months taking the position
he would not accept
15 million dollars from anyone with the
season approaching
with his agent bus cook terminated
now clowney gets the deal done to become
a member of the titans and the thing
about clowning
don't look at the three and a half sacks
last year look at the film look at the
disruption the f
up the play ability as chris sims
calls it although he'd love to say
something other than f
up the play that's what clowney does
he's a disruptive force
other guys get the tackles the sacks the
fumbles
the interceptions it's clowny who can
blow a gaping hole in an offensive line
and destroy a game plan and that's what
the titans will be counting on him to do
as they try to build on
a season that unexpectedly landed them
in the afc
championship and maybe with a guy like
clowney if he's healthy
maybe that's the difference if they get
together with the chiefs again
in the post-season and remember last
year the titans had a 10-point lead
twice
in the first half first they got to get
back to the playoffs clowney will help
them make that happen in a very crowded
and competitive
afc south hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports